من مستشفى ابن سينا في جنين الدكتور توفيق
شوبكي رئيس قسم الجراحه في المستشفى اهلا
بك معنا سيده الشوبكي نريد ان نسمع منك ما
الذي حدث
بالضبط اهلا بك اي في ساعات الفجر قامت
قوه خاصه من قوات الاحتلال لمداهمه مستشفى
ابن سينا كانت مكونه من عده اشخاص يرتدون
الزي المدني منهم من كان يرتدي زي شيوخ
ونساء بالاضافه الى انهم كانوا يجرون احد
الاشخاص على
كرسي متنقل
وم وكذلك منهم من كان يرتدي
طاقم الصحي للمستشفى سواء طبيب او حتى
تمريض قاموا بالتوجه الى احد طوابق
المستشفى والاعتداء على الكادر الطبي
هنالك ومن ثم تمت مداهمه غرفه احد المرضى
وهو مصاب يتعرض مريض يتعرض
للعلاج التاهيل حيث انه مصاب بشن نصفي منذ
ش شهر تشرين الثاني تقريبا اي تم تصفيته
هو بالاضافه الى مرافقين له احدهما كان
اخيه والاخر كان صديق
يشاركهم المساعده ويقوم بمساعده اخيه في
مساعده المصاب في القيام باحتياجات
اليوميه بحكم انه هو مريض مقعد